let's talk about net neutrality we've
been doing it every week because this is
the most under-reported story in the
mainstream news they are dropping the
ball surprise surprise
the FCC put net neutrality net
neutrality but basically the principal
that everyone had equal access to the
Internet in the Internet Service
Providers couldn't produce
your internet based on the company's
that they were
are connected with that is no longer
even though Obama said he was bored and
rowdy
the appointed telecom lobbyist who was
also campaign bundler and the guy flip
net neutrality
you can check that out if you don't
believe me I the Sunlight Foundation
publish a series ago at graft explaining
lobbyist
spending on net neutrality and I think
it pretty much explains the whole
him so giant companies the internet
company's
like a rise in AT&T and Comcast
the big boys they basically the red what
you're seeing their these are reports
that they issued through their lobbyist
that were against
net neutrality and then somehow net
neutrality
got flipped and if that's not enough
approve for you about what's going on
here that this is just about money
but look at the next one this is the
total lobbying expenditures at the top
20 organizations with the most
reports mentioning that neutrality and
yeah you're against
net neutrality you spent ship load of
mine and
on a report lobbying politicians and
then as we talk about a couple weeks ago
there was a senate Commission on net
neutrality and literally
every senator on the Commission had
taken money
from Comcast and the only one who fought
against a
without breaking because you're taking
the least amount of money so you don't
know what's going on here
it's pretty obvious at this point I to
I'm gonna keep talking about net
neutrality the night like this ship has
sailed in its really sad
a what what should we do for people that
exist in this online space
and if the last best Egypt freedom is
breaking country Heights loveeee
them the reports people putting out
report after report like
if someone gives me 1000 the report I
hate that I
that working that should not be working
what is it with politicians they love
report I was thinking the same thing
like that ever get to the politician
until they got his hand on the bike back
to pay
yeah I hope this report give me another
girl
this whitewater yeah
for their hard work for him I gotta that
report was a report yeah
I let the bottom to the tape sponsored
by the bad guy I just think I think it's
like I'll report cool where that money
again
yeah so it's so frustrating i'd its
there should be
the problem with so pressuring is the
money that they're using to buy this
influence comes from people who are
using our service coming from viewers
like you
viewers like you who are losing who are
basically paying
to pay more later that's so frustrate
yeah
and I honestly don't know what the
solution is there
is no real so immediate but it works the
same way any resource works
where the my you know the people who
have who are controlling how it's doled
out
and the scarcity a bit have all the
control yet because what are we gonna do
like I mean there's no word
there's no I can't even have like you
know a bunny ears on my aunt n anymore
and
you know some time warner and makes me
have a box inside my house
right to literally what what was free
the free to get the basic channels are
like ABC Fox where that was free
and then they went digital so you can't
not have just free television what is
public
service you can even get that thing yeah
its it it's one of the most pressing
things because
it's such a complicated process that is
unfolding not before our very eyes some
were talking very deep away
and that we can't even get to 100 it's
like my reckon credit report like I
don't know how that works but it's
affecting my life
in a yeah I do with band this is that
happen I mean if typeof
thing and we going on in every facet a
big business and the Internet
is the biggest you know a channeler
information and commerce now and it was
just a matter of time where things are
eat regulated by them kinda monopolized
by the big guys
you know and you're right we don't
understand how did this thing where
I don't know located within a series of
tubes yeah here like
rather than go they the AOL running man
we also speaking at this abilities are
we gonna look back at this time and I've
asked this before when we done this but
we look back at this order two thousand
the just about now as big as the glory
days of the Internet like 10 years from
now when it all really controlled and
throttled
and you're paying per whatever purview
her
that are we look back know how it was
pretty good back then it was pretty good
and evil playing not busy this
immediately be
not and you're bored with me but thank
you got it but it's very
yes this is big golden age right now
because right
essentially what we had in terms of you
know the way people think the kind kind
in the people want to enjoy
typically is like video-content right
and or at least there you wanna read it
on your own but if you compare it to the
way cable you still
need cable works if there's tears the
cable so if you want to watch all that
but that whole model F cable is
disappearing right and sell
that Telcom still want a tiered system
so they can charge you for more and
what's happening now is our ability to
get
around all that all these people who are
like listen I just want to sign up for
Hulu and Netflix
and have it on my watch are totally
winning the pace
so much less every month and right now
the telecom realizing that
and they want to still have that model
in there trying to you know get it that
way and they have all this money from
the old system
and they're just going to go for yeah
and if you don't think the old system
that are kinda screwed up there was this
report issued this week about how our
internet america is like
one of the worst for industrialized
nations or not even getting good service
in the first place but I guess we don't
even know it cuz when was last time you
guys are in Korea South Korea
check I would like north korea a her out